Americans are least likely to care about
kids having good manners here's what
they prioritize Instead This is again a
CNBC story
uh in 2017 only 52 percent of adults in
U.S considered good manners as an
important quality for children a
significant drop from 1990 when it was
76 percent Rob can you pull up this
article from 76 percent to 52 according
to a report by King's College London
this makes the US the least likely
country among 24 survey to prioritize
good manners in contrast Egypt leads
with 96 percent considering good manners
crucial followed by Nigeria 89 percent
obedience is less valued in the U.S with
only 21 seeing it as important for kids
Nigeria tops the list at 58 percent the
report highlights that the importance of
obedience has declined in the Western
Country since 90s with the U.S dropping
from 39 to 21 percent besides good man
honors and obedience to U.S value War
hard work 68 Independence 56 percent
imagination 30 religious fate 32 percent
amongst children however tolerance and
respect for others 71 are most commonly
considered important though the U.S
ranks 11th in this category Tom what are
your thoughts on this
you can see it every day the bizdoc Babe
is a teacher and we see it all the time
we've entered an era where it seems to
be more important that your kids are
happy and satiated right keep them happy
oh why isn't he happy and you see the
stories of parents at the you know
bribing a kid with ice cream to keep him
from having the Tantrum you've seen it
on airplanes we've seen it in malls and
over the last 20 years this new
generation it's about being happy and
satiated and it's because the parents
are not worried about the manners and
discipline they're worried about keeping
their kid happy they're worried about
satiating them there's a word for this
it's called spoiled
discipline that comes with it kids that
have rails it's a fact that they are
content and there's a word for this
disciplined they're they're content and
their disciplined they know their rails
and they have happy little lives from
that side of it when parents don't care
about their kids and and you see the
drop in what we think about good manners
they're not worried about the manners
they're worried about just keeping the
kid quiet and bribing them and and
they're spoiling kids they're not
building good citizens and when you look
at this list of things it's exactly
flipped from you know from the 80s you
know I I wasn't allowed to do tantrums
and my mom was not you know some
horrible person I was not permitted to
do that and by the way if I threw a
tantrum somebody else's mom oh wait I'll
tell you something this is great so I am
six years old I have now just started
first grade and we're in St Louis
Missouri a little town called Creve
Coeur and I take like two of my little
comic books and I put them in this bag
and I'm walking down on the street and
I'm like nine houses from where I live
this guy comes around the corner and I
don't remember the last name but he
wrote something wasn't and he says Tommy
where are you going it says I'm mad I'm
running away he stops his car gets out
and stands up and says go home because
he knew where I lived and he just yelled
and pointed down the street he didn't
spank me didn't do anything like that
but he he exerted parental Authority you
know what I did I turned around and
walked back home and as I'm turning
around he says I'm calling your mom
she'll be ready when you're there and so
he's going to his house to call my mom
and so I didn't turn out terrible but
the point is now people are worried
about oh you know you don't worry about
manners you worry about oh does he want
to be a boy want to be a girl oh the
little boy wants to be a girl give me
the dick saw here we go oh you know yeah
well yeah right I don't know what the
name for the medical tool is I just made
that up I just think it says what they
use in Missouri I think it says a lot
about Tom that even at that age he's
running away and he's like I'm bringing
reading and
you know what the hell with the
underwear and I'm bringing comic
books well I I I I I I I'm really six
years old I know brilliant I really
wanted to have this conversation I
really wanted to hit this topic because
I think it's sort of indicative of where
we're at in society as a great as
America is of everything that we've done
in our economy and the world and
Innovation and GDP and capitalism and
free markets you know uh we we are the
Envy of the world nobody's trying to
come to any other country other than
America as the American group we talk
about immigration which is a show
these days but everyone wants to come to
America but when you get to America you
realize
there's something kind of going on here
that ain't right these days okay and a
lot of it has sort of been influenced by
the suit by sort of what's going on in
social media for sure which has been
good and bad for some reasons you know
part of the uh one of the big things
that I talk about on my show all the
time is this Wall Street Journal we've
talked about here is that the uh the
Americans pulling back from the values
that wants to find us so there's been
you know patriotism is immensely on the
decline having children is immensely on
the decline and raising children
obviously that's a whole other
conversation religion's on the decline
community involvements on on the decline
but what's up is money and looking out
for yourself and selfishness and taking
selfies for that matter so what I love
about America is personal responsibility
and what we call Rugged individualism
but also and I don't necessarily believe
in the collectivism uh socialism but
there is some sort of collective
collectivism of you know it takes a
village to raise a child and I think
what we need to bring back in America
are ass whoopings because it's so easy
for any kid to go online and just talk
with zero accountability did you
see the latest interview that Tate did
with the Aiden Ross kid and the kid that
he brought on with him did you see this
door okay that freaking dork in a
SpongeBob outfit he's sold 15 years old
talking to Andrew Tate being like
I'll kick your ass bro and Tate
like a G is like oh really bro uh is
that a SpongeBob shirt you're wearing as
he's literally hitting his inhaler to
breathe he's like yeah I know how hard
it is to breathe air these days it but
the reality is this because of social
media you have these kids that blow up
online that have never have to leave
their house face zero consequences can
talk online all day as Drake says
uh trigger fingers turn to Twitter
better fingers you can act tough and
this kid right here can be punching on
the skin the green shirt look at this
freaking dork just talking what an
alpha to Tate look at this kid what an
alpha and he's like oh yeah I'll come
over there kick your ass really bro yeah
okay that's just I think that's for
eyeballs though but that's my point is
that that kid is an influencer he's like
is that a so a kid like that so what's
your name like that is a kid like that
in the real world when we were growing
up in the 80s if you talk like that
in public to an Andrew Tate he wouldn't
be walking right back I'm saying bring
back ass whoopings and and just and I
think the reason I know Adam's not I
know people can be like oh Adam's saying
beat your kids no no as all of us did
all right
there was consequences to your actions
Like Pat if you're if our parents yeah
don't don't touch this and you went when
once you got that you learned it's
almost like the Pavlov dog Theory you
knew not to do that it wasn't like I was
bleeding or or there was no fear so now
those kids once now they realize oh
they're not gonna I could touch this and
nothing's gonna happen that's where you
have kids now because the parents are
disarmed the parents they call the cops
on on their parents now now a kid goes
from I could touch this I could stay I
could do what I want you know what in
school they're telling me I could be a
girl I'm a girl and the parents like
okay okay there's no discipline and
you're right Adam I think they should we
should have a national whoop your kids
ass dead We're Not Gonna donate them no
I want to get obviously get past Japan
as a parent let me just say one thing
disclaimer I don't have kids uh all my
best friends have kids I hang out with
them every weekend I'm around all these
kids I was a teacher for two years I
taught second grade I taught seventh
grade okay I was at Camp concert I've
been around kids and
um something is going on especially
because of social media and bring make
America great again make ass whoopings a
great again I love it yeah I think I
think the standard issue and I think
parents are scared of their kids and it
makes no sense for me for parents to be
scared of kids instead of kids being
scared of parents it's extremely
confusing to see someone like that
taking place so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]